no están en tanques ni en trincheras
pero este grupo de 15 hombres y mujeres
pasan sus días y noches en las zonas más
castigadas del frente ucraniano mijailo
y su grupo de voluntarios son jóvenes y
optimistas como milana que tiene 19 años
me gusta formar parte de este equipo a
pesar de todos los bombardeos los
últimos cracks cayeron allí y allí hace
dos días yo misma limpié los escombros
daba un poco de miedo
el equipo ha estado montando un refugio
en cuya Pole una ciudad devastada de la
región de saporilla arrasada por los
obuses Y las bombas rusas unas 2000
personas siguen viviendo aquí pero
aisladas de los servicios básicos para
otras personas esto puede parecer
rutinario pero para mí es un milagro es
el único Grifo que funciona en todo cuya
Pole
y eso no es todo comida electricidad de
un generador
incluso lavadoras Esto es lo que en
Ucrania se conoce como un punto de
invencibilidad un lugar donde aferrarse
para sobrevivir quieres ducharte
mijailo es de Mario Paul donde dirigía
una empresa de software en línea y un
club nocturno en los primeros días de la
invasión evacuó a sus cuatro hijos y
luego regresó
volví a Mario por el 7 de marzo para
cuidar de mis empleados pero cuando
llegué al club nocturno había 200
personas refugiadas en el sótano empecé
a evacuarlas de la ciudad y así fue como
empecé a trabajar como voluntario cuando
resultó imposible realizar nuevas
evacuaciones mijailo acudió en ayuda de
las personas atrapadas en otras ciudades
sitiadas
como adifka
y baja mucho si quieres evacuar puedo
conseguirte una casa es un sitio muy
bonito los dueños te dejarán todo el
lugar
ahora su tarea en cuya Pole está
terminada los voluntarios montaron este
centro en una semana ser voluntario es
otra forma de luchar algunas personas
han ido a Europa y luchan enviando
dinero otras son activas en las redes
sociales comentando y retuiteando cada
uno está en su primera línea luchando a
su manera a los jóvenes les inspira a
formar parte de algo y dejar una pequeña
huella en la historia y la victoria
gracias a las donaciones mihailu y su
equipo se dirigen ahora a la próxima
ciudad ucraniana necesitada